I have an appointment your name please
sacra cog P I see a D it's nice to see
you up and around again Patrick I'm sure
you have so many memories but what is
your favorite memory playing Picard
maybe it was my first time on camera it
was a scene without in which I had no
dialogue where I encountered Jonathan
Frakes
coming out of a what do they call double
left or something and he had to give me
some bad news and I had to react to it
no dialogue and and we and I was very
very nervous I'd never been in a world
like this before I'd never worked in
Hollywood before and so he we did this
first take and the director called cut
and Jonathan Frakes said well I suppose
that's what they call English face
acting actually you might have said
British didn't really know these people
of course I discovered that he is one of
the funniest and most delightful people
you could work with memory and obviously
Picard story is still unfolding but what
do you hope the legacy of Picard will be
the eventual legacy one of Hope one of
determination and one of an absolute
determination not to give in but to keep
going to make things better I love that
it's beautiful
Issa Dodge is such a badass what was it
like stepping into the world of Star
Trek very very exciting definitely I
think getting to do a role like this is
kind of the dream of a lifetime because
as you said she's got her badass moments
which I love but she's also got so much
heart so much empathy and
just a really beautiful story of um you
know figuring out who she is and I think
getting to do that as one of my first TV
roles ever is just I I'm still pinching
myself that I get to do that and work
with Patrick and breathe the same air
[Laughter]
what was it like returning to the world
at Star Trek um it it was very very easy
because long before next generation
finished the the the space between
Patrick Stewart and jean-luc Picard had
got smaller and smaller and smaller
until finally we just overlapped and I
felt he was inside me and there were
some of me inside him as well I think
that the writers were reacting to what
they knew about me and they would put it
into the character and in our new series
19 20 years have passed since nemesis
but they've passed for me too so I'm
changed by those years so that though
that sense of change I was all set up to
bring into the work that we're doing
yeah we yeah in a sense we've all lived
it
she was only just born experience
something I experienced something in my
the hell are you doing out here Picard
[Music]
saving the galaxy Jerry I feel like fans
went crazy when they learned the Sun was
returning to Picard so how does it feel
to know that you're so beloved
that's so sweet awk about that earlier
it's such a gift to be able to have a
character that people are interested in
seeing 20 years later I mean that's
that's such an unusual thing as an actor
and it's such a just real joy and honor
and
I mean the fans are amazing none of us
would be here without fans what is your
favorite memory playing seven Wow um
this time round or the first yeah really
which one just in general
boy you know what it's not one specific
memory because it's happened over and
over but it's when fans approached you
that they felt a personal connection to
the character and she helped them in
some way so I hear a lot from people in
the autism spectrum that they related to
seven we both I think hear from a lot of
the LGBT community and trans community
that they were able to relate to the the
feeling of being an outsider that both
of our characters I think felt and
that's great when you do something that
goes beyond just entertaining people but
they can actually relate to it and it
helps them in some way that's amazing
totally Jonathan what's your favorite
memory playing you actually it's one
that's more recent which was when I
finally had a moment to reunite with
Patrick the card and I've talked a
little bit about how playing him this
time around has been much more personal
and how I've used much more of my own
life and my father's been gone now for
about 20 years and so getting to it was
such a gift to get to see Patrick to get
to see Picard as Hugh he was a paternal
figure to him so I got to really I
almost felt like I was visiting my dad
seeing him again right and like what a
gift that was in the imagination of an
actor to say it's dad you've seen your
dad again
you know that's heavy and beautiful
right so that was I mean that was a
goose bump moment for me I'm shooting
this but I let go with with Jerry said
you know sometimes it's really simple
things about playing the part like
getting a text from a person who watched
the show when they were a kid and they
were gay and they were afraid to come
out and this guy wrote me this long text
about how scared he was now he felt
isolated from his family like Hugh and
how because Hugh had the courage to move
on that he then had the courage to move
on and you just you underestimate how
important the arts are to people because
they're meat
to like get her own feelings out you
know in our own experiences so it's
those personal stories that fact the
show can still affect people's lives
it's kind of amazing yeah to see
ourselves yes it is so so important what
was it like for you guys to re-enter the
world of Star Trek so surreal so strange
because it mean it truly is something
I've never never ever ever ever expected
to be doing again and we actually both
because we're friends outside of this so
our experience with being approached to
come back to this was a little different
than anybody else's because we were at
the Hollywood Bowl dream of ours it was
one of the initial yeah okay so here's
what I'm thinking I want to bring seven
& hué back and we just kind of drank our
champagne and laughs I thought it was
hilarious and he said no I'm serious and
here's what I'm thinking it's gonna be
really cool she's really different she's
been back on earth for a long time and
it's you know it's here you're here and
he gave me some rough story ideas which
sounded really cool but I think we both
just laughed it off and thought it was
just you know drinking champagne and
saying crazy things and then he kept
bringing it up every time we would see
him and then I was at the creative arts
Emmys a year ago they were presenting
Star Trek with an award and I was lined
up on backstage getting ready to go on
behind Alex Kurtzman and he said oh so
you know we've been talking a lot about
7:00 in the writers room it's like what
oh it's so it's actually happening yeah
you know so it's kind of it's it's very
surreal putting the eyepiece back on for
the first time was very strange but fun
as the kids these days say it was extra
you know because it was extra everything
it was like figure sets bigger car
everything was just everything was just
like on steroids so you almost feel like
you're walking into a fan dream you're
like this is real I don't have to
imagine it abort Cuban on sets are
insanely massive and you just get lost
in them in a good way and everything is
amazing
yeah it really helped the performance
from my part of it hello
[Music]
jean-luc
what is your favorite memory playing
Troy laughing we laughed for seven years
and for 178 episodes than for movies we
laughed I don't think we're ever have
that experience again on any show I mean
I've done a lot of shows since and it's
I've never done I've never had an
experience like the one on TNG where all
seven of us hit it off on day one I
remember thinking we're all gonna get
fired because we're having too much fun
and we're laughing too much and they're
hot we're holding up filming and we're
all fired but that was it was a joy to
go to work every day despite the fact
that we were working 16-hour days
generally and doing 26 episodes a season
which never happens anymore
no one does 26 episodes right so what
was it like stepping back into the world
of star trek then well I did insist that
I wasn't wearing a space suit because
that was 15 pounds ago and I'm not doing
that
not losing 15 pounds at my age I will
look like a skeleton that's something
the cat dragged in so fortunately I'm
not in a space so that's kind of a clue
as to what I'm doing but I was excited
to work with Patrick and I was excited
to work with Jonathan again playing Troy
again I played her for 15 years on and
off you know she's not a challenge
anymore and as an actor you want a
challenge you know but what she lacks in
challenge she makes up for in so many
other areas so it's always just it's
brilliant it's just brilliant what was
that first moment like back with Patrick
Stewart working with him oh darling it's
so lovely to be with you again and I was
just I was in tears actually I think
when we first started because I never
thought it would happen I never thought
I'd get to work with him again I've
never thought I mean I'd worked with
Jonathan as a director I didn't think
I'd ever work with Jonathan again as an
actor so it was emotional
yeah huh what do you think Star Trek
will me into this next new generation
the same it meant to all the I mean
listen is this has going been going on
in in one shape or another for 53 years
you kind of go catch up with that Star
Wars right we'll talk when you're 53
years old right I think it's just people
expect a certain thing and if we deliver
that thing they're gonna watch agree
yeah besides yourself were there any
other favorite cameos that you can share
with us in the show characters that
we're coming back in Picard but all I
know is it's me meet Jonathan Brent and
the gorgeous Jeri Ryan yeah that's all I
know
I haven't seen I haven't seen it I don't
know you you've seen an episode haven't
you yeah well you're one up on me cuz I
haven't seen a minute of it this is
everything that ever mattered to me
I'm going with you I'm curious to know
what was your first Star Trek memory I
just have visions of me running around
slightly blind around my house with a
headband over my eyes so that's about
that's about the earliest
[Laughter]
why is it being on TV I remember
watching an episode of next generations
home I do remember Patrick's face but I
wasn't really a religious sort of Star
Trek fan but I definitely have a memory
of it being on TV for sure so what was
it like coming into this world then it
was it wasn't you know super exciting
and then I just did a lot of research I
sort of had to catch up and and watched
a bunch of episodes it's you know
focusing on next generation and just got
so into it and just started to ask
myself why was I never a fan of this
because it's great it's just you know I
love the philosophy behind it and and
you know the the human nature of it and
I was just like hooked from the Catco
that's how I felt when I watched the
pilot for this I was like so resentful
of my parents yeah I was trekking well I
thought I was a trainee because I've
watched hours but it's true
yes once you meet them once you realize
you are not even close 100 same question
for you of what what what was it like
coming into this world um it was it was
an incredible honor and also just to
join this group of people I mean I had
obviously been a fan of Patrick's from
from TNG and I mean everything and then
also theatrically Shakespeare eclis been
you know such a respected figure and
then also I was super thrilled that
Michael Chabon was going to be a part of
it because his novels have meant so
incredibly much to me and he's an
incredible writer so the idea that he
was going to be taking on something that
he loved to this degree that he and
Patrick were kind of going to figure out
a new way to take this journey was
really exciting there's so many shows
and movies what do you guys think Star
Trek is going to mean to this next
generation no pun intended or opponent I
think you know there's something what's
different about this one is the
novelistic approach I think you know at
least from the Star Trek of old and I
think you know you really hope for the
fans I think there's going to be that
that they're gonna it's it's loyal to
what the world is but it's new it's
different and to new fans I think it's
gonna just you know be something that's
just up there with the great great shows
and you know the great stories that are
being told because I think it goes it
goes really it goes deeper and this
draws a lot of parallels with today's
world so there's a lot to hold on to and
to identify with
I think Allison is such a big fan of it
growing up what was it like working with
Patrick Stewart it was incredible
I mean I am i he's such a he's such a
gifted actor and and storyteller and and
he's somebody who watching him and
watching him operated in front of some
of these convention floor so I'm just
like how do you even do that what I what
a gifted performer it's incredible
yeah he's he's a real amazing guy I need
more skill than you
the past is written
but we are left sure many people have
asked you this but what was it like
entering the world of star trek surreal
a dream come true yes just full of a
sign it's like your first day of school
yeah you've got an idea of what it is
but you don't really know really
exciting really exciting and humbling
and honoring you know I mean it's just
it's it's so good
were you guys fans before yes I was I
grew up watching on the tos movies and
the tangi series with my mom and my
sisters so they were over the moon when
I called them and told them I got the
role yeah and I the same thing I'm
watching with my family as well nice
what is your first memory of Star Trek
search for Spock TOS movie my was
actually when I got the job I sort of
had a flashback to the first time of
being introduced to Star Trek and it was
basically with my father I'm biracial my
father's black he's an actor and he
really was important for him and my mom
for us to see ourselves represented on
television and so they really encouraged
us to watch shows that would be
inclusive and Star Trek was one of the
only shows that was inclusive to all
different types of people they look
different they you know sounded
different the horror was there first
that there was the first interracial
kiss on television wasn't Star Trek and
my parents were black and white you know
so that was my my first memories of Star
Trek and so I'm getting this job you
know you see these two ethnic creatures
right here and the fact that we can sort
of do that for other children to watch
and give themselves a mirror you know
that they can see themselves represented
and that we're still here in 2400 yeah
absolutely and you have done that
because I have to say watching you I
feel like seeing women in Star Trek
they're always so put together but
seeing huge sort of be like this you
know fearless confident like so amazing
and what I love about this show is that
I feel like a whole new fan base can
sort of tune in and just hop on the Star
Trek bandwagon yeah their need to know
absolutely yeah jump right in yeah this
is a movie this is a 10-hour movie
by amazing author writers novelist
Pulitzer Prize winners you know helmed
by an incredible actor I I just had the
opportunity to go see Patrick in a
Christmas Carol in New York people have
seen Christmas Carol you know that story
we all know that story it's an old story
he played 43 characters the entire
audience was transfixed you're
transported he is an amazing you know
it's like watching a master artist so
yeah this is um something that everybody
can just jump right into and and eat up
it's so amazing you got to do that
because he only did two shows what do
you guys think Star Trek will mean to
this new generation in this next
generation hopefully hopefully a message
of hope and that there is a better
future if we all come together and put
aside our differences yeah that's that's
what I do I think that our little movie
really focuses on Humanity the value of
life of love of Hope of possibility of
solution yeah humanity are there any
characters or cameos that you guys are
excited for people to see in this show
coming down the line Jerry Ryan Jerry
yes also oh yeah oh yeah working with
them all it's been such a pleasure
amazing it's like getting the bit
watching the band get back together it
is and watching them play with their in
this story that's the best
[Music]
we'll have a story which is waiting to
be claimed
I'm curious to know how did the idea for
this series come about well you were
there and I was there yeah we were
making some short tracks which are the
little teeny wildly expensive nobody
sees interstitial pieces cbsl accents
how they were fun balanced and says it
is like oh my god Star Trek shorts oh my
god and then dollar signs so those and
we were having a some idea about a short
which actually was new Girish or that we
were imagining with a young cadet and an
overlap and then we were sort of
wondering it would be could that could
that grow up to be Captain Picard so
could we get him for one shot and then
Alec Baltazar about our partner Alex and
I think alex kurtzman modus operandi in
life is why stop there
look he's very look if you give him a
little good idea he says like that's a
good idea but it's too little like let's
quite well let's do this let's do that
we'll get this we'll get that and so you
know he didn't want to just stop why
stop with a shot of Patrick Stewart as
Picard like whatever wander for you'd be
interested in coming back and playing
the character and turned out he wasn't
well yes it was wildly public that he
was not interested in ever coming back
ever ever ever but we felt that if we
went and sat with him he would come back
and we went and sat with him and he said
no he said no just a lot of no 35 pages
we yeah and all none of which is in the
show yeah none of that no but it was all
it was a completely different story
but what it's shared with what we end up
making was a perspective on the
character of jean-luc Picard that was
that was serious and mature and about a
man who is at a later stage of his life
reckoning with his past and the things
that he's done and things he hasn't done
and trying to just decide what's next
for him and
and trying to we were just trying to
show Patrick you can trust us we we get
it we get that you don't want to come
back and be on the on the bridge of the
enterprise and have the crew and all
that you want to do something different
here's something different and even
though it wasn't the different thing
that we ended up making it was I I guess
it was enough to persuade them what we
meant what we said engage I was reading
online originally when you guys met with
Sir Patrick Stewart that you sent him a
30 page document on what the show is
about so I'm curious to know how did the
idea of this series come about we were
doing the short tracks actually and we
had the idea oh let's do a young Picard
short Trek and let's tie it into a
couple stories and as we started
building it out it became very clear
that there was way too much story for a
short and not only that but we want to
see Picard come back yeah the problem is
that Patrick said he was never gonna do
it again
so I called his agent and I said I don't
know if there's any daylight there but
do you think he'd ever sit down with us
because by that point we had really had
a lot of ideas and he was gracious
enough to do that and we pitched him I
don't know 45 minutes of story and
here's what we see for the character and
the season and he said thank you know
and we were you know we thought we gave
it our best shot I got to meet Patrick
Stewart that's a real moment for me and
you know great we tried and then Monday
morning his agent called and said you
know he's reconsidering he's been
thinking a lot about what you pitched
could you put it down just write four
pages and we ended up writing 34 pages
because we just couldn't stop and the
next time we met him he had read it and
he said I mean Wow well this show ties
in a lot of different movies and shows
so how do you balance looking back at
the Star Trek franchise while also
telling new stories and you know
propelling the universe forward I think
having started with Discovery anytime
you're going to do a new Star Trek
whether it's brand new characters like
discovery or obviously with this where
we have new characters and beloved
characters you have to honor and take
what came before you and infuse it with
some something fresh something new and
and the best sci-fi is always relevant
to what's happening in the world around
us so
also had to have a modern purpose you
know what is it saying without beating
someone over the head so you know it's a
huge responsibility in the best way to
say oh this is what is so beloved about
Patrick Stewart about Riker about seven
of nine and why did they belong in this
story well I think you guys nailed it
it's so good what was it like working
with the iconic Patrick Stewart in this
iconic role incredible was there a lot
of Earl Grey tea on set there was some
reverti
you know I think what Patrick needed
more than anything was to understand
that he was working with collaborators
that we weren't just handing him pages
and telling him to say it I think he
feels rightly so enormous ownership over
the character and wanting to protect the
character from mistakes there's so many
landmines in in doing something like
this and the collaboration was just
wonderful he listens very deeply he
listens carefully
he's very instinctual like he said to us
early on I'm never gonna be able to
write the dialogue for you but I will be
able to tell you when something feels
inauthentic to Picard's voice and that
was a wonderful compass for us because
it gave us the freedom to try things and
sometimes he surprised himself and
sometimes he surprised us and what he
could or didn't think he could do but it
was a it's been an amazing gift to be
able to work with him he's the greatest
he's also a true captain with all of the
cast I mean I'm sure any if you're I'm
sure you're gonna be talking with them
today they really all felt like he was
the number one on the call sheet in
every way he's such a leader he's like
the world's captain yeah I was telling
you guys right when I walked in here how
excited I am about this show because I
feel like you know it's a whole new fan
base can tune in and sort of hop on the
Star Trek bandwagon so I want to ask you
guys what do you think you know this
series means or Star Trek means to the
new generation I hope and we both have
young kids and although it sounds
they're not that young anymore but I
think you hope that they're going to
take the lessons from the show that we
all took which is can't we all just get
along and work towards a better future
and it doesn't really matter what your
skin color is or where you're from but
we're all coming from the same place
which is to be morally good and fight
for what's right
and I mean that's my hope for what
people take I don't think you have to be
of an old generation fan to believe in
hope I think you it to be a Star Trek
fan you have to fundamentally believe in
hope you have to fundamentally believe
that the best of us will emerge in the
future that was the beating heart of
Gene Roddenberry's vision and it doesn't
mean you don't go through dark times
Star Trek has always done that but you
say you know he's the leader Patrick is
the leader we need Picard is a leader we
need right now
I think the world is looking around and
they're saying where are great leaders
where are those people who used to give
us hope and confidence that we will
endure and that is Picard in every
possible way it's even more interesting
to put character like that in a
situation where there is so much moral
ambiguity because we're living in very
complicated times so we want to believe
that a guy like Picard could step up in
a moment like this
[Music]
you
[Music]